James is in Lexington Kentucky hi James
how are you I'm pretty good today Dave
how about yourself better than I deserve
how can I help
well I'm in something quite of a mess
right now and I'm not really sure where
to start to get out okay start with I
have currently about four hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in student loans
good lord yes I was in medical school
I had failed two sets of boards after
three years and then was recently
dismissed and so about 80 of that eighty
thousand is from undergrad and then
other courses later on to take to get
into medical school and the remainder is
from medical school all right now I have
a debt but no degreed of you know that I
was planning to use actually be able to
pay that back this point I don't really
know what my options are
dig out of this you're right that's a
mess I'm so sorry that's scary
yeah how did you get that far into it
and then not be able to pass the board's
the first two years but it was just I
think being able to I guess there's one
thing to take the exam every few weeks
every month but being able to retain
that and then the recall it to the level
of detail that I needed for the exams I
just couldn't put it all together at the
end is there any way you can re-engage
and still have a shot at finishing not
without having to reapply and then go
through the process all those again have
been all supposed to take out more loans
so what are your when did when did you
flunk the last one that was this past
spring then let go this summer okay so
what do you what since then what has
been your plan well basically just been
getting by I was able to find the job
first of all as a substitute teacher
and as hired as a high school biology
teacher but loans are on deferments
right now and I have some forbearance to
go but at this point I'm not sure any
other career options I thought about you
know physician assistant other programs
like that but it requires going into
more debt or become not in a position
where I could work and then pay as I go
what stay off the karlon bottom you know
the ones I've got now - yeah so what
would it take to be a PA from where you
are I would have to take up another year
of classes I have to take some other
entrance classes and then two and half
years for the program itself Wow then OB
that's probably at least another 70 to
60 to 70 thousand dollars in tuition and
living expenses
what about nursing it's my degree
undergraduate degree was in biology and
any had that pre-med and so none of long
there's none of the med school work
you've done applies to anything else no
none of it it's I you know I have the
debt but none of the courses none of it
actually I can transfer to anything Wow
well I mean the only thing I know to
tell you is to try to assess some kind
of a career and that's what I'm poking
out here I don't know enough about that
world to try to help you but we
obviously need to get to the point that
we're making some good money to begin to
pay this through right and so I want to
I want to lead you towards something
that's six figures to try to try to plow
through this with and/or get on maybe
with some kind of a hospital type of a
company that would do some student loan
pay for you as part of your signing
bonus that kind of a thing obviously
you're not going to be doing that as an
MD but right the PA idea is a good idea
something around the biology or medical
field but I want to move you well beyond
high school biology teacher to pay off
four hundred and thirty thousand dollars
in debt right exactly and the other
issues I'm in right now you know in 34
years old and so I have all the
that and no Satan though I have an
emergency fund but there were time for
savings nothing at all I don't know
well I'm not worried about that until we
address your income we got to address
your career track which gets you to your
income which solves the debt problem and
then solves the retirement problem I'm
not in a panic about that today I mean
if you were 66 I might be but but you're
not you've got time to work through that
you've just got a reset here and land on
your feet from a career standpoint and
find something that you can use this
biology and medical aptitude that you
have short of MD to try to get some
income coming in James that's all I know
to tell you man I'm sorry you're facing
this Wow